[Applaudissements]
merci jérôme et notre avis dame si ce
format sont très sympa oui zilina mans
je vais leur répondre parce que vous
êtes dangereux
vous me parlez des hommes et les hommes
on s'en fout c'est pas les hommes qui
sont harcelés dans le métro c'est pas
les hommes qui ont des problèmes et
c'est pas les hommes qui sont battus
quand on voit des femmes objets comme ça
c'est dangereux c'est dangereux pour
l'image de la femme mais vous vous ne
vous en rendez pas compte vous voulez
pas le voir c'est ce que ces messieurs
elle est dangereuse il tue est persuadé
que les gens qui regardent la télévision
sont des imbéciles
aujourd'hui tous les gens qui regardent
peut-être mais pas les gens non et
jean-pierre la télévision ont deux
second degré qu'on connaît parfaitement
les mondes pas tous mathieu sur un
corner